just before 1 30 p.m yesterday we were
called reports of a shooting outside
Saint Aloysius Church in Phoenix Road
Camden
officers responded with paramedics and a
crew from the London air ambulance
they found multiple people with injuries
caused by pellets from a shotgun
Four Women
aged 21 41 48 and 54 were taken to
Central London hospitals where
thankfully their injuries were assessed
as non-life-threatening
the 48 year old woman has sustained
potentially life-changing injuries
two children were also injured
12 year old girl sustained a leg injury
she was treated at hospital before being
discharged yesterday afternoon she is
expected to make the full recovery
a seven-year-old girl was more seriously
injured
she remains in a hospital in in hospital
in a stable but life-threatening
conditions and our thoughts are with her
and her family
the incident took place as mourners
gathered outside the church following a
funeral
we believe the suspects discharged a
shotgun from a moving vehicle
which was a black Toyota CHR
likely a 2019 model or similar
this was a shocking incident
people came here to attend a funeral
to be with friends and loved ones and
mourn together instead they were the
victims of a senseless act of violence
we know it would have had a significant
impact on communities across Camden
and we will have a visible police
presence in the local area in the coming
days and weeks to provide extra
reassurance and as your neighbor's
superintendent I'm not sure that will be
happening
I can promise that we are doing
everything we can yeah it's definitely
to identify and bring to Justice those
who are responsible for this attack
yeah the investigation is being led by
the Mets specialist crime command
we have a significant number of
specialist detectives and local officers
working around the clock but we also
need the Public's help
we want to hear from anyone who
witnessed the incident or has
information about it
your information could be vitally
important no matter how insignificant
you think it is
please call the Metropolitan Police on
101 or Crime Stoppers anonymously on
0800 triple five triple one
thank you very much